salut à vous de bon matin une petite
vidéo bonus on va parler de mentalisme
et on va aussi parler de réflexion et
castle cet étrange objet composé de
quatre parties est un casse tête duquel
il faut réussir à enlever la boue bhl
encore une phrase étrange sur ma chaîne
youtube mais on va y revenir dans
quelques secondes
je profite juste de cette vidéo pour
vous dire que si vous êtes du côté de
rochefort-du-gard d'avignon dans cette
zone là je suis ce soir en spectacle à
rochefort du gard
ça se passe à 21 heures dans le cadre du
festiv du rire j'y jouerai une heure de
mon nouveau spectacle lui que je vais
faire l'olympia et petite cerise sur le
gâteau comme le festival est soutenu par
la mairie les places sont à 5 euros et
10 euros
voilà vous avez le lien dans la
description est temps qu'on en est à
faire un point je joue mon spectacle
donc à partir de septembre le nouveau
spectacle à l'olympia sa part en tournée
dans plus de 40 villes
vous avez les infos sur mon site
internet qu'est dans la description des
qu'une billetterie ouvre ses portes bim
je mets le lien sur le site et on va
attaquer ce fabuleux objets qui me rend
ouf je le trouve extrêmement jolie la
manière dont est faite la boule est déjà
très joli et la manière dont ils pensent
et le casse tête et sa résolution est
très jolie vous avez tous les ans sur la
chaîne youtube l'été j'aime bien faire
un concept alors cette année le concept
est beaucoup plus simple que les autres
années je garde le principe de faire une
vidéo tous les mercredis à 6 heures du
matin je change pas parce que comme ça
vous savez une fois que mercredi s'ils
seraient passés y ait une nouvelle vidéo
et chaque semaine vers 12 d'un casse
tête mais pas forcément des comme ça je
me suis aussi procuré des niveaux dix
sur dix sept sur dix des boîtes à
ouverture secrète comme la pandora box
et donc je ne sais pas encore si je
réussirai à ouvrir tous les casse tête
mais je pense ça peut être sympa de
faire ça ensemble mais évidemment il y
aura pas que des casse tête je vais
alterner les vidéos de castet du
mercredi avec une vidéo qui sortira je
sais pas quand ou geoffrey soit des
démonstrations de choses qu'il ya dans
mon nouveau libre de liens description
évidemment très très bonne petite
lecture d'été soit des astuces de
mentalisme courte moyenne longue je veux
j'en sais rien ça dépendra des astuces
pour cette première vidéo donc j'ai pris
un casse tête de difficulté 4 sur 10 je
crois en fait sa particularité est très
simple c'est qu'il faut pas voir la
boule comme un ensemble et pas voir
l'entourage comme un ensemble si on
regarde bien la manière de le chercher
on n'a aucune action possible c'est de
faire ça et de tourner la boule
donc on sait déjà de base que ce sera
pas la bonne solution puisque le geste
qu'on peut faire au départ sur les
casquettes et souvent pas de bon j'ai
commencé par lui parce que c'est un
élève préférée et que celui-ci gelé
depuis longtemps donc forcément je l'ait
déjà craqué attention petit spoiler
alert
là je vais le resulat devant vous donc
vous le voulez je vous mets le lien
d'ailleurs dans la description et bien
ne regardez pas tout de suite la suite
il faut l'imaginer
encore une fois comme quatre parties
différentes et non pas comme deux on est
biaisé parce qu'on pense qu'un à 2000 en
a vraiment 4 puisque la boule et dans
deux pièces différentes
ce qui fait que si vous aligner comme ça
la séparation des deux blocs ainsi que
la séparation des deux boules
alors vous n'avez plus qu'à tourner un
petit peu comme une vis et les deux
parties se déferont et forcément les 4
partis également
c'est à cause de ça que ça me casse tête
préféré parce que je trouve que la
manière qu'ils ont eue de taille et la
boule pour avoir cette idée est
complètement dingue
regardez juste comme ça je vous met une
vidéo très courte sur instagram
aujourd'hui sur mon nid gtv vous pouvez
suivre mon instinct agrémentent cliquant
là où dans la description de la
résolution de comment le défaire et ont
prêté leur faire parce que le but d'un
casse tête c'est dans les deux sens je
vous mets ça dès aujourd'hui comme ceux
ci voulaient voir vous allez voir ça sur
un star penser à liker cette vidéo mais
tu es un petit commentaire des
casquettes que vous aimeriez que je
raisonne vous des astuces que je traite
pour cet été
cette vidéo me permettait aussi de vous
donner le programme des deux mois à
venir j'espère que vous êtes peut-être
déjà en vacances et que sinon ça va pas
tarder à arriver
pensez à vous abonner à très bientôt
cher